تحذيرا صحيا مهم لكل من يتناول كوب قهوه
او يحتسي الشاي وهو يتابعنا الان اليكم
هذا التحذير اذا اضفت اي نوع من المحليات
الصناعيه البديله للسكر الافضل ان تحضر
وربما ان تتوقف عن استخدامك بالفعل منظمه
الصحه العالميه مشاهدينا اعلنت في بيان
رسمي ان الاستخدام طويل الامد لبدائل
السكر الصناعيه قد يؤدي الى الاصابات
بازمه قلبيه وايضا امراض مزمنه اخرى
كالسكري كما وضحت بان المحليات البديله لا
تساعد في تقليل دهون الجسم على المدى
الطويل كما هو شائع ونصحت بتقليل السكر
بشكل عام في نظامنا الغذائي
هلا بالمطلق كل شيء هو صناعي اكيد بيكون
منه منيح للجسم كل شيء طبيعي احسن للجسم
الدراسه يلي عملتها المنظمه العالميه كنت
عم بقراها قبل ما اجي بتقول انه
هي الفوائد تبع المحليات الصناعيه فوائدها
بس على
فتره كتير قصيره لانه نحن عم نخفف من نسبه
السكر تنقدر نخسر من الوزن بس الاشخاص
اللي رح يعتمدوا كل حياتهم على استعمال
المحليات الصناعيه
باكلهن اليومي ويقطعوا السكر الطبيعي
ويقطعوا الفواكه على المدى البعيد عم
بيشوفوا انه هذا
السرطان
على السرطان عم يعمل سرطان عم يعمل سكري
لانه عم بصير جسمنا ما بقى يتعرف على
الجلوكوز اللي هو السكر الطبيعي اللي نحن
بناخده مشان هيك بيقولوا انه المفضل انه
ما نكون كتير عم نستعملهم بحياتنا
اذا حدا مثلا والدراسه على فكره من عملت
على اللي هم عندهم سكري على الطبيعي
بس على الاشخاص العاديه مضبوط فمشان هيك
بينصحوا على طول انه مثل ما نحن صرنا عم
نخفف من الملح خلينا كمان نخففها من السكر
هل ستيفيا اليوم تغنينا عن السكر هل هي
ايضا من ضمن المحليات تدخل في هذه الدائره
انه كثره استخدامها قد يضر الجسم
طبيعيه بس لنحصل على السكر من الاستيفيا
هو بيتحول بالمختبر او بالمعمل لحتى يطلع
لنا هالباودر يلي نحن بنستعمله كمحلفه
كمان بينحط من ضمن السكريات الغير طبيعيه
فكمان كثره الاستيفيا مثل كثره الاسبرتام
وغيرها كمان بتوصل لتعمل بنفس سوق
المحليات
لازم يكون منيح